Wildfires spread across Western and Central Europe...
...as a drought stretches into a second month.
Nine people have died and several more are in critical condition...
...after being poisoned at a funeral in southern rural Peru.
Officials say this is the second incident of poisoning they've seen in recent months.
In Italy, police have arrested 11 people, including a nurse,...
...in the crackdown on two Palermo-based criminal organizations.
Officials say the gangsters tortured drug and alcohol addicts...
...in an insurance fraud racket.
In the U.S., NASA is sending a spacecraft that will make history...
...by sitting four million miles away from the sun.
NASA hopes this mission will help gain insight...
...as to why heat from the sun gets hotter away from its center.
Finally from China,...
...as the United States releases Disney's live action "Winnie the Pooh" film,...
...China bans the movie from entering theaters,...
...causing the movie to lose the world's second largest film market.